le verdict était très attendu par les
familles des victimes des attentats du
11-septembre mounir el motta sadek vient
d'être condamné à 15 ans de prison c'est
la peine maximale pour son implication
dans les attentats au tribunal de
hambourg patrice ramdane impassible
lorsqu'il pénètre dans le tribunal
mounir el monte à sadec le reste à
l'énoncé du verdict depuis il écoute le
juge reprendre quasiment tous les
arguments de l'accusation
les relations financières avec les
kamikazes les services rendus
les séjours en afghanistan dans les
camps d'al qaïda pendant deux heures des
faits rien que des faits et au final
cette impression sans lui la tragédie du
world trade center n'aurait peut-être
pas eu lieu
15 ans c'est bien c'est un terroriste
coupable d'avoir aidé des gens qui ont
tué trois mille personnes
et comme le juge nous l'a dit il est
coupable pour ceux qui ont non seulement
tué mais aussi plongé beaucoup de
familles dans la souffrance et le
chagrin motta sadek en prison ses
avocats qui avaient plaidé
l'acquittement échafaude l'hypothèse
d'un second procès motif le tribunal de
hambourg n'a pas entendu cet homme ramzi
binalshibh arrêté à karachi il ya cinq
mois il croupit aujourd'hui à guantanamo
les américains ont refusé de le laisser
témoigner
un second procès est peu probable mais
s'il a lieu il ne suffira pas à effacer
certains témoignages embarrassants pour
l motta salek ne l'at on pas entendu
dire un jour à taille et notre pilote il
prépare quelque chose de grand et à la
fin on dansera sur la tombe des juifs